[Music]
I'm Chris Brian this week we're talking
about hold okie techniques so how do I
escape when someone grabs me in Aikido
it's very important to understand that
the system was built to deal with
multiple attackers that is an important
emphasis in Aikido and I believe the
whole structure of the system is built
around dealing with this idea you wish
Shiva said in an interview that anything
that was one-to-one was not enough for
him so he had to be able to deal with
multiple attackers that was super
important in his rules of Aikido his
second rule was you can't just prepare
for the person in front of you you have
to real prepare for people all around
you so multiple attacker situations in
Aikido are absolutely important and we
have to understand them in order to
understand Aikido so today in that vein
we're gonna talk about Nina and Dori so
two attackers grabbing us and the basic
concepts we're gonna use with Nina and
Dori I'm gonna call Josh out here and
Maya and we're gonna go to work Josh
Maya okay so we're gonna talk about Nina
and Dory's what if two people are
holding us many gives the same basic
fado key concepts as I would use for one
person the only thing is I have to take
it the other person into account
understand that it's gonna give me some
problems and there are a couple things
that will actually kind of help me when
there's two people one of the problems
is that I want to create much
interference with these two as I
possibly can so when there's two people
on me I want to knock them against each
other
the main problem I'm gonna have is I
have twice as much force right so that's
a pretty big main problem how am I gonna
deal with that so let's say these two
both grab me here on my shoulders right
so just double shoulder grab both you
guys okay there so they just got me like
this right this is just a neutral
position we can kind of look at okay now
they're going to be doing something so
they're probably going to be trying to
get to my body or my hands or whatever
like fighting them from my knife out
then they're gonna be trying to get to
my hands if I don't have a knife out
they're gonna be trying to get to my
body so how am I gonna suss that out
well the first thing I want to do is see
if either one of them is pulling on
right so if one of them is pulling on me
or both of employment so it doesn't
matter I both can pull on me okay good
so now they're both follow me so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
who's pulling harder now right now
Maya's pulling harder than Josh so I'm
gonna help Maya pull Josh okay now we
created a little Kazushi in Josh - Josh
kind of broke off mountain now from here
if Maya's in this position I might have
a coke - Naja if I got rid of her that
would be great but what's happened is I
started to get some motion going the
last thing I want is to be stagnated in
this position because these two are
stronger than me so they're gonna
overcome me so the first thing I have to
do is figure out what sides pulling
harder and then go with that so that
simple so if Josh is pulling harder I'd
go with here and Josh and I strength
combined with pullaiah which is great so
even if mine was a big beast Josh and I
together could probably pull her now the
second I pulled those guys together I
want to get out of the area of
contention so right now I'm right smack
dab the air and contingent if you look
at our positioning this is a trap it's a
terrible position so what I'm gonna try
and do is use food and wash you to slide
out of this so once I pull here I'm
gonna try and get those two into each
other and that's what I'm looking for
now look that looks pretty iq2 stuff it
might not turn out that beautiful but
that's the main idea of what I'm looking
for I want to smash them against each
other as hard as I can and that
hopefully gives me a little bit of
breathing room
they might not both let go but maybe
what I'm gonna let go and one will
change positions or all kinds of things
can happen but that's the main idea of
what I'm looking for so here I'm gonna
decide which sides pulling harder and
then can I get out of the area of
contention so right now neither of them
slowing large that's fine with me too
now one looks pulling hearts and now my
search blowing art so I joined with Maya
we pull Josh as josh is coming in I want
to see if I can get him to meet Maya
right there now even if they didn't let
go so mine was being a sweetheart over
here and made it easy for me but let's
say I bang Josh into my head - got the
iron grip here
now once Maya has that iron grip like
this I'm gonna start working out of it
right so notice I found their arms up
getting my still got that Andrea that's
fine I'm gonna work my regular
principles of Hinoki once I have them
smash together so I want to get them in
each other and get out of the way of
that so I let them deal with each other
while I'm moving now one or two things
will happen
they'll get smart and go I need a better
position that means they let go they let
go winning for me because I'm out of
there or they'll hold on they hold on I
continue to work and work and work
pushing them against each other and
twisting them up so it's very similar to
working with Rio casa
sheera ryokan that these are the basic
concepts to begin to work mean and
Dorrie I'm Christopher Hine thanks for
watching
[Music]